Abba reached out because they wanted us
to help promote their new find and to
flip now I'm a fan of foldables that
flip vertically I think it makes a lot
more sense because you have a full-size
phone and then you can make it smaller
so here we have the Z flip 4 and we're
gonna compare it to the find and to flip
now I already took this out of the box
you guys see that cool presentation and
I did set it up and I have to say that
right out of the get-go I was impressed
I was showing it off to Angelica before
I even read uh the key features about it
I noticed the lack of crease now we've
tested many foldables and companies say
it's not that noticeable it disappears
but you always notice it but with this
thing take a look at that you literally
do not see it at all now with the flip 4
Samsung has improved the crease but it's
still visible even when you're using it
with the screen on compared to the 5
mind and two flip where I don't see it
at all and then if you turn off the
screen I mean you guys see that
difference right there the crease is way
deeper and more prominent where with the
find you don't even see it and that is
because instead of using a U-shaped
hinge they're using a water drop one
which has a larger Bend radius and that
along with their flexion hinge
technology which combines all the cams
slides and gears into one using high
strength steel with very fine accuracy
and they tested it up to 400 000 folds
so I think it's pretty cool you guys see
the end result even the hinge here is
very smooth instead of being a bumpy and
then of course that flat display instead
of having the visible Bend now the next
thing that surprised me wasn't the huge
display on the front which did surprise
me but it was the fact that in this box
we still got a charger in the Box we
haven't seen this in a while and and
this is a super vook charger so it's
going to be super fast we have the cable
here where of course with the Z flip for
you don't get a charger in the box so
the fine N2 flip can charge at 44 watts
compared to 25 watts so that means in 30
minutes instead of charging to 50 it
charges to 62 and that's with having a
larger battery they packed 4 300
milliamp hours in here compared to 3700
that's nearly the capacity of the z-fold
4 which is much larger and because of
that you do notice that the z-flips
battery drains faster in real use now uh
screen on time for this thing how we use
it it's about five hours with this
you'll get about seven because a larger
battery and the screen's adaptive with
this thing and they somehow did that
with a phone that is the same size of
the flip 4. now here on the sides we
have a button layout that is similar but
the buttons are larger and a little bit
more clicky on the Oppo and the
fingerprint sensor on the side sticks
out a bit more so it's easier to find
than the recessed one now with most
foldables you notice what looks like a
screen protector already have some dirt
on here that's getting stuck but it is
not a screen protector you don't want to
remove that that is designed to protect
this plastic display but with this Oppo
you don't see that at all because
they're using a multi-layered shielded
screen that uses utg glass that is
thicker while decreasing the crease and
it increases the impact protection by
300 percent so that is a nice
Improvement that's something that I
noticed right away now let's go ahead
and flip to the back now this display
here is massive let me turn on the one
on the Samsung here look at that
difference guys we have full color right
here bam I have my settings that I can
turn on on the Samsung you have this
mini screen you can get some weather do
it timer
see some alarms some very basic things
and then for a lot of it you press it
and you got to open up your phone to
actually be able to continue and see my
calendar right there now with this I can
literally start taking a photo watch let
me hit portrait here
bam look it's telling me flip your phone
the other way to get a better angle
alright I can go through all my settings
here I can pull this down let's move
over there's our weather right there
let's move it right there look at that
my timer I have all these options I
could pull down my settings right here
and make adjustments and turn something
off really quickly and then of course I
can pull up and have a nice list of
notifications so having this large
vertical screen as you guys could see is
much nicer than having this small
horizontal display you know what let's
go ahead and compare the cameras and
we'll use the cool selfie mode which
allows you to see yourself using that
screen so you guys can see right there I
can see myself but it's horizontal so
let's go ahead and take a picture here
and that is what you actually get so the
picture is vertical I have a bunch of
the ceiling in here and that was one
issue with this phone before now let's
try
the Apple I'm not even gonna open up to
enable that mode because it pops up
right away
let's hit photo here all right I see a
vertical photo of myself
and let's do a portrait shot
bam I can even open it up on here see
the full thing
you got your multi-touch you can zoom in
that is a much better experience now I
know that this video is sponsored by
Oppo they want to show it off but even
without that this is a lot better this
is what you'd want to choose and of
course you can use this folded and they
now have the new feature called waist
level framing so you can enable that
right there so if you're walking around
you want to get some lower angles of
your kids a bug or whatever you have to
get down all the way to ground level to
have to do that you see the image on the
bottom portion of the display now the
main camera is a 50 megapixel compared
to a 12 we also have an 8 megapixel
Ultra wide and then on the front we have
a 32 megapixel camera compared to a 10.
now as far as the UI we have one UI
versus color OS and here you guys see
the layouts and everything both these
have high refresh rate displays and
here's the difference in HDR quality
looks like the Oppo does get get
brighter as both these set to 4K
playback and you guys can see the
difference in the colors and and the
detail and now let's go ahead and do a
speaker comparison
[Music]
all right guys let us know your thoughts
on the sound quality in the comments
section below and now let's compare the
performance the flip 4 has the
Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 whereas the find
N2 flip has the mediatek demensity 9000
plus you guys see the full specs right
there let's go ahead and run the CPU
Benchmark and here are the scores you
guys could see that the mediatek is
actually beating out the Snapdragon
processor both in single core
performance and in multi-core
performance so with that said the fine
N2 flip isn't the first foldable on the
market but comparing all these different
aspects it is definitely the best one on
the market and once again Vadim and I
were just admiring that lack of a crease
throughout all of these testings and the
fact that it closes completely flush
without having that big gap in there so
if you're looking for a foldable and
you're comparing between
both of these I would take the Oppo as a
daily driver over the Samsung because of
that crease the design and obviously
that huge screen on the back go ahead
and check out the links down in the
description below thank you for
subscribing using that button above
checking out those other videos right
over there and thank you to Oppo for
partnering with us on this video and
promoting this excellent new phone